there's another stark warning about the
battle against the coronavirus this
morning the institute for health metrics
and evaluation at the university of
washington
warns the u.s death toll could top 317
thousand by december 1st if social
mandates are eased
it comes as the country edges closer to
having at least
6 million covet 19 infections 46
thousand new cases were reported
on friday health officials across the
country are leaning on the centers for
disease control
to revise its latest testing guidance
michael george has more
criticism of the centers for disease
control heightened this week
after the agency indicated testing
people without covet 19 symptoms
was not needed even people in contact
with the virus
if we stop testing contacts we lose
information
about what's going on our own community
dr tom inglesby of the johns hopkins
center for health security is among
those
critical of the cdc we know that
something on the order of forty to fifty
percent of people with this disease in
the united states
don't have symptoms testing data has
guided policy makers for months
six months so we're we're getting used
to living in it san francisco's mayor
first to lock down a major city is only
now
cautiously opening nail salons and gyms
for outdoor business only now it's time
for us to make some levels of transition
san francisco's strict rules
included mandatory masks and cases and
deaths have been relatively low
and in ohio new data shows a dramatic
drop in cases since july 23
when the state mandated masks all
individuals should sit
six feet from other people even alabama
a state slow to act is telling fans to
put masks on
at high school football games and the
governor wants them to keep them on
we should not be deceived that being
vigilant against covet 19 during the day
ends when the football game begins
in addition to cdc cutbacks the
coronavirus has hit government budgets
new york facing a 1 billion dollar
shortfall
may have to cut even emergency workers
i don't want to see this happen i have
told all new yorkers that we're getting
to a point where we're starting to run
out options
new york's emts already stretched to the
limit including the ones here at this
station but
the city says if they don't get some
federal aid fast they may have to cut
hundreds of first responders in the next
few weeks
michelle that would be catastrophic
michael thank you